[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome, everyone.
It's my pleasure to introduce
our next speaker in the series
of Talks at Google.
So several months ago,
I had the opportunity
to go on a volunteer
trip to Uganda
with eight ladies, most of
whom I hadn't met before.
But one of those
ladies stood out
because of her professional
background and the fact
that she was an athlete, but
also because she just brought
a lot of energy to the group.
RAHA MOHARRAK: And
the the big hair.
SPEAKER: Brought a
lot of energy, brought
a lot of excitement, and
also really very passionate
in working with the
children in Uganda.
So that person is Raha Moharrak.
She's most known for
her athletic feats.
She's the first female
Saudi to climb Mt.
Everest.
And she's also the youngest
Arab to climb the seven summits.
And we're super thrilled
to have her here today
and to hear her story.
It's very inspirational,
and I hope you enjoy it.
Before she starts, we'll
just watch a quick video
of her greatest climb.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Thank you
all for coming, by the way.
I know it's a Thursday.
Hang in there.
[APPLAUSE]
I'll make it worthwhile.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Why do I climb mountains?
Because I was told I couldn't.
No one believed I could do it.
But I'm not the type
that gives up easily.
Being the first Saudi
woman and youngest
Arab to climb Everest was so
far from what people expect.
I completely shattered
that stereotype.
The memory and the feeling
of that accomplishment
lives on beyond the mountain.
I felt like I belonged.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Give her an
an even bigger round
of applause, because she
actually just completed
that last--
RAHA MOHARRAK: I
finished the summit.
[APPLAUSE]
It's the first time
I see that tape.
I get a little bit
emotional when I watch that,
because it's the first time
I see it since I actually
finished the seven summits,
which is less than a week--
three weeks ago?
I still have really ugly toes.
Don't tell my mom.
But yeah, I can't
believe it, but I finally
finished the seven.
And I always struggle
with starting my story.
Because when you
hear Saudi women,
that's not what you expect.
I mean, I know.
It's a bit shocking.
So I'm going to start
from the beginning.
And I would love to give
you a cool reason why
I started climbing.
Because I was trying
to find myself,
or whatever would make
me sound like a badass.
But the truth is, it
started with the word "no."
Just "no."
Such a small
two-letter word that
has the power to enrage a
spirit and kill the soul.
It's a two-edged sword can
either hurt you or heal you.
The best thing
anyone has ever told
me once was a very quiet "no."
It was almost a whisper.
I'm going to start
from the beginning.
I was born in
Jeddah, Saudi Arabia,
to a father who always taught
me to reach for the stars,
and to a mother, whose
spirit I inherited.
According to my father, you
and your mom, copy-paste.
Same [INAUDIBLE].
So we have the
same kind of spark.
People call it a headache.
We call it "character."
So from as long, as teeny-weeny
as I could remember,
I was different.
I knew I was different.
They knew I was an
awkward little child.
I didn't do the typical things
most little girls, for example,
did.
And although I felt
a bit of an oddball,
my family never
asked me to change.
My family never made
me question who I was.
But I did feel like
I was different.
So for the longest
time, I tried to stay
inside this little box of
what a Saudi girl should be,
the typical Saudi girl.
I really, really tried to copy
my girlfriends that I grew up
with, but I couldn't
fit in that box,
no matter how much I tried
to conform to the norms.
And as I grew--
remember, being a little
girl is not the same
as being a woman in Saudi.
So as I grew, so did the
walls my gender imposed on me.
Because when I was a little
girl who liked sports and was
boyish, it was kind of cute.
But when I was a woman and
I was being more boyish
and I wanted to play
with my brother's friends
rather than my
sister and dolls, it
started to become uncomfortable.
And I couldn't fit.
And I said, I will never try
to be anything other than who
I really was, even back then.
So I was at a
crossroads in my life.
I knew I had two choices.
Option one is go
behind this thing that
drove me since I was a child.
I knew I was destined for more
than just what they expected.
Or option two, which is more
the traditional lifestyle
of going from
wedding to wedding,
waiting for Prince Charming to
come and sweep me off my feet.
Ladies, I mean no insult. A
lot of people dream of this,
especially in my culture.
It's like the ultimate goal.
But it was never meant
to be the path I walked.
I speak my heart.
I wasn't actually
meant to walk a path.
I was meant to climb one.
So I finally reached
this conclusion,
and I said I'm going
to find this thing.
I'm going to find the
answer to this thing.
I didn't even know
what the question was.
So I was searching.
I was so confused,
but I never gave up,
because I knew that there was
something out there for me.
That's a lesson I taught myself.
Even if you're
sometimes lost, even
if you're sometimes confused,
don't settle for normal.
Don't settle for just
being comfortable.
Live it.
I almost gave up.
I thought, maybe they're right.
Maybe I should go back to Saudi
Arabia and wait for [INAUDIBLE]
to come and--
But randomly one day--
I kept my heart
and my mind open.
Randomly one day, we were
sitting with a group of people,
and this woman I
didn't even know
said "I'm climbing Kilimanjaro
over the Eid holiday."
As soon as she said that,
I looked at her and I said
"You're doing what?"
She says, "Oh, I'm
climbing a mountain.
It's the highest
peak in Africa."
And this little fire in my
heart, this little thing
just ignited.
And I said, "You're
climbing a mountain."
She said, "Yeah."
And she started
to talk about it.
And the more she talked about
it, the more I was like,
it's sporty.
It's outdoorsy.
It's dangerous.
It's as far away from
Saudi as possible.
I found it.
This is exactly what I'm going
to do to piss my family off
and to also change my point
of view of myself, right?
I was still nervous
about booking everything,
so I started telling
people I'm going
to climb Kilimanjaro in Africa.
And everybody was like, you're
Saudi, and you're a woman.
Everybody was just giving me
this really annoying answer
like, "What?
No, no.
You can't do this."
And that was the final push.
I was hesitant.
I wasn't sure.
But when people
started telling me
I couldn't climb a mountain
because of the color
of my passport, I was insulted.
I looked at myself
and I found nothing
lacking in my capability.
I have two legs.
I have a brain.
Why am I less than anyone else?
And that was it.
It cemented my idea.
Of course, it's not
enough to have an idea.
I'm a Saudi woman, after all.
So I still had to have the
courage to actually confront
my family with it.
It wasn't enough to just say
I'm going to climb a mountain.
I still had to confront
my poor father.
So for the second
time I almost gave up,
and I said, "Oh, maybe
this is too much.
Maybe they're not going
to like the idea."
But still, that little
thing in my heart pulled me.
And I said, "You know
what?"-- my love of adventure
far exceeded my
fear of rejection.
I said, "I'm going to call him."
Thank God I was in Dubai.
He was in Saudi at the time,
so it wasn't a face-to-face.
So I called him.
As soon as I said, "Hi,
Daddy," him knowing me so well,
he was like, "What did you do?
What did you break?
What's wrong?
Do you want money?
What's up?"
And I said, "Nothing.
I just, you know, since
I have some time off now,
I've decided to climb the
highest peak in Africa."
As you can see, I
speak really fast.
I just went, "It's this high
and it takes this long."
I was like a broken
Wikipedia page.
And the man didn't have
a chance to say a word.
And in reality, I was too
scared to hear his answers.
And I just went--
[SPEAKING GIBBERISH]
When I stopped, he said, "No."
He just said no.
And it was so loud.
I'm telling you,
it was a whisper.
It was so loud in my mind.
He just said, "No."
Not wanting to
insult him, I was so
upset, I hung up
because I was really,
really aggravated by his answer.
I hung up, and I went
home and could not sleep.
I couldn't let it go.
That small, trivial word
grew in my mind till it was--
it had claws and it was
grabbing at my soul.
I'm like, "How could
he say no to me?"
So I decided to write
this long email.
And I'm severely dyslexic,
so I was writing like this.
And the sun came
up by the time I
was done writing my phone book.
It was a long, long email.
And I threw every single thing
he taught me straight at him.
You're the one that taught
me that I'm [INAUDIBLE]..
You're the one that taught me
that I can reach for the stars.
You, you, you!
You're the one that made
me believe I could do this.
How are you giving
me a ceiling now?
me a leash now?
How could he do this to me?
And I tried to be as
politically correct as possible.
Because, again, Saudi, you know.
Dad, you can't really just
say, "I'll do what I want."
And I spell-checked and checked.
And I had my finger
on the send button.
Now, I've been on 14
expeditions, seven continents,
including a mountain that
tried to kill me twice.
And that was the top four
scariest moment of my life.
And I took a deep
breath, and I sent it.
I would love to tell
you that I went to sleep
and everything was
fine, but the reality
was, I ran around [? myself ?]
like a headless chicken.
Thinking, "Oh my god.
What did I do?
My dad's going to
send my brother
to put me in a box with
a bow, and my mom's
going to go [INAUDIBLE].
Anyone, anyone take her.
Anyone marry her."
I was thinking [INAUDIBLE].
But I was thinking I could
hear the [INAUDIBLE]..
I was like, "OK, I shot
myself in the foot."
And to add to the
drama, my dad, who
speaks to me almost every day--
yeah, I know it's embarrassing,
but he does.
He calls me almost
everyday-- ignored me.
We always dispute
how long it was.
I say it was, like, three weeks.
He says it was three days.
But it depends on who you ask.
And he ignore me.
And throughout this--
I call it the Silent Days.
Throughout the Silent
Days, I was afraid.
I was emotional.
My tummy was hurting.
I couldn't sleep.
I was every single emotion
you could think of.
I was a walking,
talking Pandora box.
But the only feeling I
did not feel is regret.
Not once did I regret
sending that email.
And that's when I knew.
I was terrified, but it
meant the world to me.
I knew how much
this meant to me.
I would also call my mom, and
my mom's on the inside now.
[WHISPERING] She's like, "I
don't know what you told him,
but he's not talking very well."
At the end of the three days,
few weeks, whatever it is,
he replied one sentence.
He said, "You're crazy.
I love you.
Go for it."
That one line.
I sent him a full book.
He sent me that one line.
And neither him
nor I nor the world
would imagine where I'd end up
after sending that the line.
Of course, I called
him and I said,
"I need a verbal confirmation."
And I got approval
from my family.
A few weeks later,
maybe a month later, I
find myself standing
on Africa's roof.
I was very hypothermic.
I had snow blindness,
nearly snow blindness.
I couldn't feel half of my
limbs, but I was so alive.
I don't understand
how going to a place
that I've never been
felt like going home.
It felt so familiar to me.
It felt so real, so my
own that I was addicted.
I knew that would not be the
last time I stood on a summit.
I knew that would not be
the last time I tasted what
it feels like at the summit.
And as soon as I came
back down, my parents,
I walked into the house,
wind-burned and everything,
I looked like a six-month-old
[INAUDIBLE] and I was so happy,
and they looked at each
other, and they said, "Uh-oh."
They knew that
there was a problem.
And they were right.
I could not stop climbing.
I kept climbing one
mountain after the other.
I kept hiking and kept doing--
anything you can imagine
that I could climb,
I kept trying to do.
Until I thought I
reached my limits.
I thought I reached
my ultimate goal,
until I saw that beautiful
mountain for the first time
with my own eyes.
And I was in love.
My mom always says,
"You know this one?
I wish one day you
will look at a man
the same way you
look at a mountain.
She looks so happy."
She always says that
when we have aunts over.
She says, "You look at
it like it's your love."
I'm like, "Yeah, but
I love mountains."
So I saw that beautiful
mountain, and I was infatuated.
I remember prior to seeing
it, I had done one mountain.
I had done one, Kilimanjaro.
And I saw it, and I
said, "You know what?
I'm going to climb
Everest in a year."
I gave myself a year.
I said, "In one year,
I'm going to come back
and I'm going to
climb that mountain."
It's a bit arrogant.
I don't know what I was
thinking, but I came back,
and in the span of a year
I did eight mountains,
a lot of emails back and
forth between my dad.
Because every time I came
back, they were like,
"It is last one, yes?
Raha, it is finished.
Please, leave.
Finish."
Two weeks later,
I'm like, "You know,
Dad, here's a mountain
I thought of climbing."
So a year and eight months-- a
year and eight mountains later,
I was on the Hillary
Step, and I was taking--
the Hillary Step, for those
of you who don't know,
it's a pathway
that everyone needs
to pass if you're climbing
Everest from the east side.
It's named after Edmund Hillary,
who is the first man that
climbed Everest.
So me, a Saudi girl
from Jeddah, was
standing in this
little walkway about
to reach the highest
mountain in the world.
And I can't explain to
you how that meant to me.
It didn't matter that I was
a woman or Saudi or brown.
It didn't matter.
I was doing what I loved.
And I was living it.
I had men shoulder to shoulder.
My teammates were all with
me, and it didn't matter.
Because I was
doing what I loved.
I was doing what people
told me I could never do.
And honestly, I often worried
that climbing this mountain
would be a selfish act,
more than a selfless one.
Climbing is a selfish sport.
It's very difficult.
It's dangerous.
It takes a lot of time.
But all my worries
melted away the day
a little girl came
up to me and said
she decided to ask her father to
ride a bicycle because she read
my story.
And for those of you who
don't know, riding a bicycle
was outlawed for
women up to 2013.
I had to learn how to ride
a bicycle two years ago,
because we were never
allowed to ride bicycles.
So this little girl
came up to me and said--
well, actually, we were
communicating online.
And she said she decided to
climb a mountain, and to me,
that is an honor.
And if at the end of the day
you walk out and completely
forget about this crazy Saudi
woman who's climbing mountains,
I want you to remember that
at some point in time, me,
who's standing here, who
grew up here in the desert,
from Jeddah, I stood
on top of the world.
A Saudi woman touched the sky.
What are you capable of doing?
If I could do it, then your
dreams are not far from reach.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: So we have some
time for Q&A. And just to get
started--
think about your questions.
But just to get started, so
you mentioned the importance
of your family and
the way that they
raised you to be able
to conquer your fears
and do whatever you want.
But not everyone has the luxury
of having a family like that.
So what would be
your advice to people
who don't necessarily
have that confidence,
have that [INAUDIBLE]?
RAHA MOHARRAK: I think the
majority of-- especially
the region, of people,
and especially women,
are afraid of failure.
They're afraid of failing.
So they're afraid of
hearing the word "no."
If you're hearing the
word "yes" too much,
you're not doing
something that's worth it.
You're not doing something
that's moving you.
So don't be afraid to hear "no."
Don't be afraid to be put down.
Think of it as an invitation.
They say "no," you tell
them, "You know what?
I don't agree."
Always have that openness
with your family.
And especially in
the Arab world,
it's really hard sometimes
to sit them down and say,
"I know this is what
you want me to do.
I know this is what you believe
is the right thing to do,
but here's my point of view."
It's very hard
for us to do that.
So always have an
open conversation,
and never be afraid of failing.
SPEAKER: And was that the
mentality that you took into--
RAHA MOHARRAK: Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
SPEAKER: Or going to Denali.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Denali.
So long story
short, that mountain
really nearly killed me.
And not just physically.
Emotionally, mentally,
it took me a year
to be able to put
my gear back on.
My jacket and my boots.
I would get--
I had some PTSD.
I couldn't put my gear on.
And I had to work really
hard to get over this,
the fear of the mountain.
But then I realized
my fear of giving up
is bigger than the mountain.
So I killed myself
training for the last year.
I didn't end up finding
a sponsor, which
was a big letdown.
I thought I can find a
sponsor at least for the--
I mean, I don't mean
to care about records,
but you'd think I'd get
a little bit of backing.
I didn't even get that.
But in the end, my
father was the one
that said you need to
get-- basically set
it up to go back to Denali.
Him, who was--
SPEAKER: He came back around.
RAHA MOHARRAK: He was the one
that pushed me in the end,
and he was the one that
sponsored the last climb.
Because he knew that I
would probably wake up
a few years down the line and
think "I regret doing Denali."
Because it was my last one.
And I hate giving up.
So yeah, I can't believe
I did it, actually.
SPEAKER: So considering that was
your supposed last one, what's
next for you?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Lots of beach
time for the next three weeks.
I always have been and I
always will be a person
that strives to be happy.
So whether it's climbing,
or hiking, or hopefully
down the line, I really
want to help people.
I was explaining it earlier.
I want to represent a cause or
to champion a cause, hopefully.
And just to live happy.
I have a big thing on my bucket
list, which is actually a book.
But it's a hidden, a big thank
you message to my parents
for not killing me years go.
So it's my memoir,
but it's-- honestly,
it's commemorating my mom and
my dad for being honestly such
amazing parents.
Even though they
stood in my way,
they really have changed
what it means to be
a Saudi parent in this day.
Because we didn't
lose each other.
And it was hard
for them socially.
They kept getting a
lot of negativity.
Every time.
Every time I go to a
wedding and you see it.
So Saudi weddings
are segregated.
I'm a bit taller than Saudi.
So I walk in like a [ARABIC].
You know, I walk in with my mom,
and then you'd hear them, "Oh,
who's this [ARABIC]?"
[WHISPERING]
I'm here.
I'm not deaf.
I'm athletic.
It's not-- so there's
stigma, and my parents
had to endure this.
I can endure it because I
don't care what anyone thinks.
But they had to endure it, so
it's a big thank you to them.
SPEAKER: That's
a lot of the work
that you're doing right now is--
RAHA MOHARRAK: To
change the mentality.
SPEAKER: To encourage,
to change the mentality.
RAHA MOHARRAK: If I exist,
you can't tell the other girls
like me [INAUDIBLE] don't exist.
Yeah, so hopefully.
AUDIENCE: So how much of
it is actually physical
and how much of it
is like a mind game?
RAHA MOHARRAK: I
love this question.
I've climbed with triathletes.
I've climbed with overweight
people a little bit.
I've climbed with smokers.
I've climbed with psychopaths.
I've climbed with narcissists.
I've climbed with
beautiful people.
I've climbed with so
many different people.
It doesn't matter.
If you don't have the right
mind, your body doesn't matter.
Your body's enough to
get to the mountain.
Your body is enough to arrive,
but what keeps you going
and what keeps you
alive is your mind.
I once saw a guy triple my
height cry like a little baby
because he had a blister.
It's difficult, but a blister?
Patch it up, suck it up, and go.
But because he's been
climbing for three or four
weeks, and a majority of
men have higher muscle mass
than women.
So what happens
when you're climbing
with less oxygen for
a month to your body
if you are mostly muscle?
You deflate.
Muscle survives on
oxygen. So these machos, I
call them "the roosters."
These machos that show up
with the glasses and [ARABIC]
There's a lovely
word in Lebanese--
[LEBANESE]
OK, you know?
Thank you.
They show up.
Yeah, I need this right now.
These guys show up, and
then a month down the line--
so mentally they break.
And I've seen them.
They're not as
fast as they were.
They don't sleep well.
And their mind just goes--
So if you don't
have a strong mind--
and I've climbed with
a guy who had one leg.
And this guy was an ex-military.
He had one leg.
He carried the same
weight we all carried.
And I did not hear
him complain once.
He would arrive at camp.
I know I'm sidestepping, but
I saw this with my own eyes.
He would arrive at camp.
Because they would duct
tape his prosthetic leg
so that it stays.
He would arrive at camp.
They'd cut the duct tape.
They'd take off
the prosthetic leg,
and then he'd shove the stump
into the snow, and you see--
because it's so hot.
He never complained.
And on the high
side, there was a guy
complaining about a blister.
So mind.
Body gets you there,
body gets you moving.
What keeps you alive and
surviving is your mind.
I mean, I'm not a
very big person.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: How much physical
training did you need to do?
RAHA MOHARRAK: So
for Denali, because I
was so nervous about Denali,
I trained for two months.
In two months straight, I had
eight days off in two months.
AUDIENCE: And what does
that training require?
RAHA MOHARRAK: It's
every-- it's cardio.
It's cardio endurance, strength
and conditioning, and stamina.
So training would be two hours,
two hours, two hours a day.
Or four hours, one shot.
Or actually twice
I did six hours.
So I was in the
gym for six hours.
Thank god for Netflix, because
I was going to shoot myself.
So I had my iPad and I
was carrying 25 kilos.
And it's called conditioning.
And you don't have [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Who was
the lady who told you
she would climb Kilimanjaro
and inspired you?
RAHA MOHARRAK: She wasn't a
very close friend of mine.
AUDIENCE: But she was Saudi?
RAHA MOHARRAK: No, she
was Palestinian-Iraqi?
She wasn't even my group.
She wasn't even someone
that was close to me.
She was just someone who
was in the right place
at the right time.
AUDIENCE: And you
know which complex?
Did you meet her in [INAUDIBLE]?
RAHA MOHARRAK: No, you know in
Ramadan tents a lot of people
pass by.
AUDIENCE: My first question is--
RAHA MOHARRAK: You
have to do sit-ups.
AUDIENCE: --now that you've
done Everest, do you have
another job that you're eyeing?
RAHA MOHARRAK: I
just finished it.
Now I'm eyeing the beach.
[? The train. ?]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
the second question,
I think you were the Lipton
brand ambassador, right?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so do you feel
people recognize you now more
or they know who you are?
How was your experience
after Everest?
Like, people seeing you.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Refreshing.
AUDIENCE: "Are you
the lady from that ad
and did you really
climb Everest?"
RAHA MOHARRAK: So I
was really, really,
really nervous when
Lipton approached.
Lipton is huge is Saudi, and I
was just like, "I'm not sure,
but I really need this
to climb the mountain."
I wasn't really sure, but
I give them so much credit
for having the guts to back me.
They've never done that.
They've never had
a female Saudi--
a female, period,
to back the brand.
And as soon as it
launched, I was like--
I had my hand in my heart.
But as soon as my dad called
and said, "This is amazing!
I want to send it to everybody!"
I was like, "It's
gotten approval
from the Saudi people."
Because I worked really
hard to make it authentic.
I don't know if you've seen it.
It's here.
And I didn't show anything.
It was--
[THUD]
What was that?
SPEAKER: Sorry.
RAHA MOHARRAK: And we shot
in Austria in December.
Not very [INAUDIBLE]
Actually, [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's this.
And I've noticed so many
girls come up to me and say,
[SPEAKING ARABIC].
It's really cute.
And I always for two seconds
when people say, "Are you
the girl?," I'm always
like, "I don't know
what they're going to say."
But let's say half-half
I get "oh, this is great"
or "this is stupid."
One of my favorite stories
is, I had an event in Riyadh.
24 hours I have my bag.
Did the event.
I'm flying back.
I forgot my lucky Swiss
Army knife in the bag.
And this knife has been
with me all the continents
and all the climbs.
And the guy was refusing to let
me go on the plane with this.
And they were about
to close check-in,
and I don't have a check-in bag.
And I made such a big hoopla.
It's this big.
And if you want to laugh,
I'll show you the video,
because I was taking the video.
It's this big.
And I was like, "I'm
not going on the plane.
I want--" I crossed check-in.
So they called the biggest
guy, the police man,
because I made a big deal.
I'm like, "I'm not throwing it.
Get me out.
I'll wait another flight,
but I'm not throwing this."
So this head guy with, I
don't know, 20,000 stripes
came up to me.
And he's like, in Arabic,
[SPEAKING ARABIC]..
He's like, "What's the problem?
Why?
Why does this mean
so much to you?"
I held it.
I'm like, "This
thing saved my life.
I had it with me in
seven continents.
And I climbed the highest
mountains in the world with it.
I'm not letting it go."
He was very proud.
He looked at me.
He said, "We only have
one mountain climber,
and you're not her."
I'm like, "Really?
What's her name?"
He said "Raha Moharrak."
I'm like, "Really?
Open the passport in your hand."
He had my passport.
"Open it."
He opened it.
He's like, "Whoa!
Taller than I thought."
He goes, "Oh, let her pass.
Let's go!"
And he made me princessa.
So I do get negativity, but
the positivity washes it away.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RAHA MOHARRAK: It's just,
I'm very, very lucky.
AUDIENCE: After the
beach, because you
seem pretty adamant on getting
more woman to not just do
these things and have the
bravery to do these things
but also give themselves
the chance to discover--
[THUD]
SPEAKER: Sorry.
I'm not trying to draw
attention to myself.
RAHA MOHARRAK:
[? Nadia, ?] you're
taking away my [INAUDIBLE].
Joking.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Where was I?
RAHA MOHARRAK: You were asking--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so after
you're done with the beach,
because a big part of
it is not just women who
want to do different
things, it's
women giving themselves
the opportunity
to know that they want
to do different things--
you seem pretty adamant on
making sure that happens.
RAHA MOHARRAK: So I try my
best to associate myself
with international
movements that are trying
to help women in the region.
For example, I spoke on
behalf of Human Rights Watch
a few times in New York,
in Women in the World
and in Frankfurt for their gala.
So by associating myself with
these people, who advocate,
I have a point.
I'm not just standing
there on stage and talking.
As fun as this is, my
message is, we need sports
because it's a health problem.
We have vitamin D deficiency.
We have brittle bone problem.
We have a lot of problems
in most of the generation
because they don't
do any sports.
So I try as much as I
can to lead by example,
and also to highlight this
issue, to try to go to schools.
But like I said, they don't
really invite me much.
AUDIENCE: You mean
outside of Saudi?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Outside of Saudi,
I think they're confused by me.
I think they don't
know where to put me.
No offense to anybody, but I'm
not a fashionista and I'm not
a [? contour-bontour. ?]
Everybody's in love with--
I mean, everyone likes
a little bit of contour,
but it's not really my thing.
Everyone likes a
little bit, especially
with the light on my nose.
Yeah, I admit it.
But they don't know
where to place me.
I tried to find an
agent many, many times,
and they don't know
what to do with me.
So from my end,
I'm trying as much
as I can to associate myself
with the right advocacies,
like I mentioned.
It's really
difficult. Sometimes,
I wish I was
[? contour-bontour. ?]
It's easier.
No offense.
You guys look great.
SPEAKER: I think we have
time for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Back to the mountain.
RAHA MOHARRAK: I'm surprised
that, yeah, not many
about mountains.
AUDIENCE: So when you
were on the mountain,
did you have any of your own
set of rituals or superstitions
or things that you
would do for yourself
to keep your mind in shape
during obviously some very
difficult times?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah,
I did, actually.
I had a few rules I followed.
[INAUDIBLE]
I ate like an ogre.
I peed like a race horse.
I slept like a queen.
[INAUDIBLE]
It's essential.
AUDIENCE: Mantra.
RAHA MOHARRAK: It's essential.
I'm not big, but you
have to feed yourself.
Because a lot of people
go and they don't feed.
Anything that they
put on my plate--
and I'm a picky eater--
I would eat.
You have to.
And then you have to
force yourself to relieve,
to go to the bathroom properly.
I know it sounds
funny, but there's
no such thing as toilet.
You have to do a toilet break.
And trust me, it's
uncomfortable when
you have a harness on
and boots and everything
to go to the bathroom.
So you have to learn
how to manage your body.
And sleep is such
an important aspect,
because you can
be fittest person
and not be able to calm your
mind to sleep on the mountain
and you're useless.
And you're useless to the team.
And when you're
useless to the team,
you're not going to continue.
The other thing is, I had a
very interesting relationship
with fear.
A lot of people say,
"Well, you're not afraid."
I'm always afraid.
Accept the fact that
you're going to be afraid.
Don't say, "Oh, no.
I'm not afraid."
Because that's when arrogance
comes out and that's
when mistakes happen.
I'm always afraid, but I
managed what I was afraid about.
I tried as much as I can
not to chase the rabbits
down the rabbit hole.
These terms are all mine,
because I can't explain them.
When you're climbing
for so long and you're
disconnected with
your family, things
start coming in your head.
"Is my family OK?"
"My knee is hurting me."
"There's a sound
in my shoulder."
And you start feeding yourself
these doubts and these fears.
So you really have
to manage them.
One of my favorite
sayings-- and I'm
going to watch it,
because I don't
remember who said it-- they say
that if you have two wolves.
One is fear and one is bravery.
Which one will be stronger?
And the answer is,
the one you feed more.
So as much as you can, try
to feed the positive side
of your brain.
Stuff comes up.
I remember sometimes
I was freaking out
that someone was sick or
I was getting injuries,
but you really have to have a
healthy relationship with fear
and manage it, not
deny it completely.
I think there was a hand.
AUDIENCE: After the
beach, after relaxing,
do you see yourself embarking
on another physical challenge?
Do you see the next
set of mountain ranges?
RAHA MOHARRAK: So if my
parents are watching, no.
AUDIENCE: Yeah?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Nothing.
I think I will always have
an adventurous spirit.
I love it.
It's part of who I am.
I mean, it doesn't
necessarily have
to be high altitude mountains
that want to kill me,
but the world is so
vast and beautiful.
I have such a long
list of things to do.
So I think I'm going to
continue to do these things
and hopefully not give my
parents heart attacks, but just
a smaller level.
Really, there's so many
ranges I want to do.
I want to go back to
Antarctica, because I loved
that, the whole scene there.
But I don't think I can stop.
But I finished the big ones
I wanted, so now I can relax.
I think there was one more.
I don't want to leave anyone.
AUDIENCE: Just very quick one.
Do we have time?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
could argue that--
RAHA MOHARRAK: And you
also have a question?
SPEAKER: No.
RAHA MOHARRAK: No?
OK.
AUDIENCE: You could argue
that maybe one or two of these
are really, really long
difficult hikes as opposed
to climbs.
Which one would you say was
the most difficult technically?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Technically?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Denali.
Denali.
There is two types of mountains.
There's an assisted mountain
and a non-assisted mountain.
An assisted mountain is like
Kilimanjaro and Everest.
Kilimanjaro being
a smaller version,
because people help you porter
your stuff at their stations
and you don't have
to carry everything.
They are assisted.
They are non-expedition.
An expedition style,
which is Vinson
in Antarctica and Denali,
you are a walking everything.
Kitchen, house, everything.
Bathroom.
So you need to carry your
entire gear and entire food
for three weeks or
four weeks or whatever.
So you start off with
a 25 kilo backpack.
And attached to it
is a 25 kilo sled.
And eight kilo worth of
rope and emergency gear.
And I was 60 kilos at the time.
And you're not
walking in [ARABIC]..
You're not walking
into the [INAUDIBLE]..
You are on inclines with--
I'm so happy I'm wearing
closed shoes today, by the way.
Because they're purple.
And not the cute
purple people paint on.
You really jam your body.
I had bruises on my collarbone.
I had bruises on my hips.
And you need to everyday
be able to carry that.
And I'm surprised no one asked
about the bathroom situation.
I'll tell you, because
it's really interesting.
SPEAKER: That was one of the
first things I asked about
in my email.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah,
she asked about it.
So all the mountains
are different.
Some mountains
have potty places,
but the most
interesting is Alaska.
Because Alaska, you have
something called a CMC can.
We can't end on this now.
Someone has to ask me a
nice question after this.
It's called a CMC can.
It's green.
And by law, you have to
go number two in the can.
You can't go anywhere else.
You'll get a fine.
Number one, there are
what we call pee wands.
Which is basically a yellow
wand where you pee in.
So number two, you
don't each get a bucket.
You get a bucket for a team
or four buckets for a team.
AUDIENCE: You have to carry it?
RAHA MOHARRAK: You need
to carry the shit bucket.
And if it's your day to
carry the shit bucket,
you don't give shit.
You get the bucket and
you carry the bucket.
Well, it's locked.
It's not like
oozing or whatever.
Thank god.
It's locked.
And thank god, it's
Alaska, so it's frozen.
[LAUGHTER]
But someone was asking.
A guy once told me
and said, "So what?"
And I was so angry
in that event.
You guys are lovely,
but that event
was not a very positive vibe.
And I look at him.
I'm like, "Let me
see how you feel
carrying a shit bucket
for three weeks,
and then tell me this is easy!"
So you literally
have to carry it,
because by law you
cannot dispose of it.
Because it's a national park.
So on the expedition, you
have to carry everything.
The stoves, the tents.
It's a lot.
It's a big load.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
get rid of the bucket?
RAHA MOHARRAK: So you carry--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Really?
You really want to know?
RAHA MOHARRAK: There
are different areas.
If you are below
a certain point,
you lock it and
you carry it down.
Because you're already
past the point.
If you're above a
certain point, they
have very big crevasses
that you can dump it in.
And that's an allocated one, but
it's only maybe one in every I
don't know how many meters.
So technically you're
carrying the poop bucket.
AUDIENCE: It's with
you the whole way?
RAHA MOHARRAK: You pretty
much have to carry it.
It depends on the company.
Some companies, the
guides carry the bucket.
Thank god.
Like, the last time, the
guide carried the bucket.
But the one I did before,
you carried the poop bucket.
And everybody was just
like, "You do what?"
And I told my mother
and she nearly fainted.
[INAUDIBLE]
My mom studied in Egypt.
She's like [SPEAKING ARABIC]
"You're doing what?"
She had this horror
face, but it's
a lot of-- it's extremely
difficult to climb
expedition style.
And if, like I said, you're
a team, and if you're not
a good team, they'll catch you.
They'll put you down.
They'll let you go down.
They will not allow
you to get to it.
SPEAKER: And a typical
time for an expedition is?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Oh, all the
mountains are different.
The smallest one is a few days.
The longest one, which was
Everest, was two months.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah, so my
record of not showering--
again, sorry, Mom--
was 22 days of not a
single drop in my hair.
[LAUGHTER]
And if you're all curious,
I just posted all about my--
I'm not going to show
you the poop bucket.
But on Instagram,
the last three weeks
was my day-to-day of Denali.
So If you're
curious, have a look.
It's so embarrassing, but
it gives you a good insight
about my climbing.
We need a good
question before we go.
I can't end on a
poop bucket note.
AUDIENCE: Just wondering,
how many calories
did you eat a day?
And you had to carry all
this on your back, so--
[LAUGHTER]
RAHA MOHARRAK: I've been
asked that many times.
You know, I've never
actually calculated, but I--
AUDIENCE: I imagine like 3,000?
4,000?
RAHA MOHARRAK: I once won
the eating competition
in Antarctica.
It was me and 14
Marines, and I won.
Yeah, so you eat a lot.
I don't know the exact number.
A question that's not
related to pooing or pooping?
AUDIENCE: Did you
plan your food?
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah.
The climbing company is in
charge of managing your food.
I'm milk-intolerant
and I don't eat pork.
So this company I
had was amazing.
So they had-- some people
are gluten-intolerant,
which is incredible, yeah.
But I [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah.
I answer myself, by the way.
If you have any
random questions,
I answer myself myself.
Hence the bad spelling,
but yes, I answer myself.
AUDIENCE: I was always
hearing that sometimes
when people go for expeditions
and somehow they feel--
some of them leave.
Others need to go back
to camp and so on.
I heard that the first
time you tried to climb--
RAHA MOHARRAK: Denali?
AUDIENCE: Denali?
You couldn't do it.
When did you feel that your mind
was stronger than your body?
And how did you know you
should stop, not go further?
RAHA MOHARRAK: What's
the most dangerous thing
on the mountain?
What would you assume?
AUDIENCE: Not going back.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Give me answers.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Oxygen.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Your arrogance--
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
RAHA MOHARRAK: --is the number
one killer on the mountain.
I've seen so many--
and quote me.
I've seen so many people die.
Yeah, like bodies.
Of course, there are a lot
of [INAUDIBLE] avalanches.
Things happen.
Something breaks a lot.
But I saw with my own eyes.
Because before I
went to Everest,
I was like, "How
can someone die?"
can this happen?"
And then when I was climbing
Everest, and I was on the way
down, because I was very
fast on the way down,
there will people
coming up crawling.
Crawling in ice.
Why would you do that?
Why on earth would
you crawl to anywhere?
And they were crawling.
And most of them, if
they don't get help, die.
So in my case,
Denali was a simple--
the weather was bad.
The team was weak.
It's a mountain.
Come back another day.
It broke-- it almost broke me.
It took so much for
me to accept that,
but I lived to see another day.
Why would you do that?
So the number one
thing that kills people
is arrogance and lack of--
I've seen it.
I've seen people
like, "Let's do it.
Superman."
And then you see
them crying later.
Why?
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
The mountain is dangerous.
The mountain is perilous.
Anything can happen.
And then after that,
you're being arrogant?
And that's why I get
very annoyed when
people say "conquered Everest."
I didn't conquer anything.
I was a little flea on a
giant's back, and he was asleep,
and I had a chance to go
up and look in his eye
and come back down.
You don't conquer a mountain.
You're just lucky
to have a shot.
There's a great writer
called Jon Krakauer.
He wrote "Into Thin Air."
If anyone knows this book, don't
read it you're on the mountain.
AUDIENCE: Did you read it
before or after you climbed?
RAHA MOHARRAK: On the mountain.
Yeah, I read it on the mountain.
It's about the tragedy
that happened in '97.
About 40 people died.
And he says that we are humans.
So yeah, what made me
come back is, [INAUDIBLE]..
Plus, the weather was bad.
We had many things
to come back down,
but I wouldn't even continue.
SPEAKER: I think
that's a good end.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Yeah,
it's a very good end.
Don't ask me about poo again.
But I'm here for a bit.
Like I said, I do
answer my stuff.
Don't make fun of my
spelling, but yes, I do.
And if you have
anymore questions,
it's honestly a pleasure.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much.
RAHA MOHARRAK: I took
some time to get me--
SPEAKER: Yeah, but we
finally made it happen.
Thank you so much for coming.
RAHA MOHARRAK: I'm
sorry I talk fast.
SPEAKER: No, this
was really wonderful.
Thank you so much.
RAHA MOHARRAK: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]